[Music]
on this Saturday night protests
supporting Iranian women spread
worldwide
we would like them Canadians people
around the world
to stand with us tens of thousands
converge in major cities everywhere
sparked by the death of a woman in
police custody
the global solidarity and the marches
here in Canada
saying bye-bye to Canadian travel
restrictions and Airport mask mandates I
feel great it's almost back to normal
this is awesome what you need to know
the next time you fly
uncovering Ian's damage plenty of
Warzone right now yep the help the cost
and the coast still without power and
imagine a dating site minus the dating
instead swipe right for a co-parent then
you want them to be more involved in the
kid's life the real Modern Family and
the future of fertility
[Music]
global national
for a Nasser
good evening to you and thank you for
joining us from Tehran to Toronto from
Vancouver to Vienna in as many as 150
cities worldwide a sea of solidarity for
Iranian women after weeks of deadly
Nationwide protests there sparked by the
death of a 22 year old woman Masa amini
died after being arrested by the
so-called morality police for allegedly
wearing her hijab too loosely
[Music]
in Toronto two visibly emotional women
holding back tears cut their hair to
stand hand in hand with the women of
Iran
when they are done the two Embrace and
they're met with Applause from the crowd
for more than four decades women in Iran
have risked their lives walking into the
streets without fully covering their
hair the practice of cutting hair which
has been showing up at demonstrations
for amini also represents an ancient
Persian tradition that is a symbol of
mourning but these protests they go far
beyond hair and the head scarf they are
rooted in combating oppression and
safety in a country that has one of the
highest female execution rates in the
world
there has been outrage like this several
times over the past 40 years but
protesters hope this time is different
and gives them the only solution that
they want real change Tom Vernon now
with tonight's top story
they came in waves holding flags and
Banners thousands of Iranian Canadians
and supporters took to the streets of
Toronto to honor Masa amini and to
demand Justice in the young woman's
death our main
it was just over two weeks ago the 22
year old amini died after being taken
into custody by Iranian authorities
allegedly for wearing her hijab too
Loosely her family says she was severely
beaten Iranian police deny the charge
they say she died of a heart attack for
15 days Iranians have taken to the
streets women defying the regime by
waving their hijabs in the air it's very
important for people to see
uh for house many years people have been
fighting for very basic rights Dr Kathy
rondavarti is involved in the Vancouver
rally a movement she hopes will grab the
attention of all Canadians and force
politicians here to act we are together
we're angry we want our rights and we
will continue
this has become an international
movement in Madrid Spain this woman cut
her hair in solidarity with the women of
Iran all of them are important to me and
this is the symbol of that huge crowds
also gathered in Paris waving flags and
holding signs that included phrases like
standing together Against The Barbarians
let's go
in London they chanted Masa imini's name
and demanded the government there take
action
prime minister Justin Trudeau and the
Biden Administration in the United
States have each announced sanctions
will be put in place including against
Iran's morality police although the
exact details of the sanctions have been
scarce in 150 communities around the
world women and men gathered to march to
demand Justice hopeful that this time
the world will hear their call and
change will come for those standing up
in Iran I'm angry inspired and hopeful
and frustrated all at the same time Tom
Vernon Global News Edmonton
Afghan women were also on the streets
protesting a suicide bombing where
dozens were killed in wounded Friday and
demanding better security from the
taliban-run government
the demands come after an attacker
detonated a bomb during an exam at a
private tutoring center Friday in an
area that's home to the minority Hazara
Community the official death toll stands
at 19 killed and 27 wounded even though
it's expected the death toll will grow
most of the victims are female students
Taliban officials condemned the attack
and the group spokesperson says they
would find the perpetrators and they
would bring them to justice
as of today all covid-19 travel
restrictions have ended in Canada
Travelers arriving in the country no
longer need to show proof of vaccination
or use the controversial arrive can app
The Mask mandate has also been dropped
meaning wearing a face covering on
planes and trains is now optional though
it's still recommended most passengers
at Vancouver International Airport are
welcoming the changes
no I don't have to worry about getting
back I know I'll be fine everyone will
be fine I found that arrived Canada act
like a lot of people
not really user friendly friendly until
you did it two or three times we made it
through the last two years
it doesn't hurt us
to take a little extra care I'm okay
with it I'm just I make the choices for
myself so I'm vaccinated but I'm still
wearing the mask
the federal government says the
restrictions were able to be lifted
because the latest covid-19 wave has
largely passed and travel related cases
aren't having a major impact but an
Alberta infectious disease physician
says the mask mandate removal could lead
to a surge in illness this fall
you know when we're going into viral
respiratory season is this really the
time to remove mask mandates for planes
I would say no I think that it is you
know it's just one extra layer of
protection I think for most people it's
really not that much of an imposition
we go to the US next where hurricane Ian
has been downgraded but the death toll
is rising there as it makes its way
across the Carolinas this is the search
for survivors intensifies among the
ruins of Florida's flooded homes now at
the same time officials are assessing
the damage and what's being called one
of the strongest and costliest
hurricanes to ever hit the U.S and as
Jennifer Johnson reports it's now
pushing its way further north
the storm surge from Hurricane Ian has
left Coastal communities in the
Carolinas underwater and many without
power The Surge came at high tide as Ian
continued its deadly Trek along the U.S
east Coast there is damage there's some
heartbreak there's work to be done but
South Carolina was spared the worst
nothing compared to parts of Florida's
Gulf Coast just gratitude just nothing
but gratitude that we're here we
shouldn't be alive right now with that
storm this is at the power of that storm
these ladies like many on Florida's
Sanibel Island tried to ride out the
hurricane now little is left of that
popular vacation spot those getting off
the island are being rescued by boat
yeah this area got it more evacuations
are being issued in Sarasota as a levy
threatens to break other Floridians are
finally returning home for the first
time since the hurricane hit finding
scenes of total devastation it's hard
it's a neighborhood that's been here for
a while some people have lived here for
40 years the head of the Federal
Emergency Management agency is taking a
first-hand look at the damage estimating
rebuilding Florida alone could cost up
to 47 billion dollars we have already
started the planning efforts for what
it's going to take to rebuild these
communities but also recover in a way
that makes them more resilient
U.S Coast Guard officials are surveying
the damage in Fort Myers where roads are
now littered with boats the city of
Warzone right now yep the Florida Army
National Guard is handing out food and
water hundreds of thousands are still
without power
officials are expecting the death toll
to rise as search and rescue efforts go
on this is like the entire world just
came crashing down on us we worked
really hard to have it and now it's it's
gone recovery efforts are just beginning
this powerful ferocious hurricane
punished Millions now it will take many
months and in some cases years to put
these communities back together
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
people in Cuba
from Hurricane Ian hundreds of people
chanting and banging pots and pans as
they March through neighborhoods the
storm knocked out power to the entire
country of 11 million people on Tuesday
in Havana electricity has only been
restored to about half the residents
Cuban officials are hoping to have the
lights back on across the country by the
end of this weekend
just as he did in Crimea eight years ago
Russian President Vladimir Putin is
again seeking to redraw the map at the
barrel of a gun the Kremlin announced
plans to formally Annex four regions in
Ukraine after holding bogus referendums
earlier this week Putin said he would
defend those regions as if they are his
own but Putin's move to draft hundreds
of thousands of Russian men into his war
machine is now facing resistance at home
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson joins us now with more
Mercedes
pharah Putin has gone all in in his war
against Ukraine but there are growing
signs he may have overplayed his hand
world leaders have condemned Russia's
sham referendums held in four occupied
regions of Ukraine prime minister Justin
Trudeau has said Canada will never
recognize Russia's annexations
announcing more sanctions against the
regime meanwhile Putin's moved to
conscript hundreds of thousands of
soldiers has prompted an exodus at
Russia's borders with thousands of
would-be soldiers desperately fleeing
the draft Russian authorities have
arrested hundreds with angry
demonstrations breaking out not only in
Moscow and St Petersburg but in remote
regions of the country Putin's plan
would see young Russian men sent to the
front lines in Ukraine with minimal
training supplies or functioning
equipment the question now is just how
far does Putin think he can go I spoke
with one of Putin's fiercest critics
Bill Browder he told me Putin sees his
invasion of Ukraine as an existential
war with his own fate as Russia's
president hanging in the balance the
reason he went into this war was he felt
like there was a chance he would lose
power and he needed a good War to
solidify his support so now he's in a
situation where he's losing the war
um looking weak and so all he knows how
to do in a situation like this is
Escalade Browder said there's more that
Canada and the West can do to tighten
the screws on Putin and his regime that
could include sanctioning more oligarchs
as well as countries helping Russia to
evade sanctions still as winter
approaches it appears that Russians and
ukrainians are stealing themselves for a
bloody drawn out conflict Farah
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
Mercedes and you can watch the whole
interview with Bill Browder on the west
block tomorrow morning right here on
global
if fixing our Health Care system is a
priority where's the plan coming up our
latest edition of Global's code blue
series asks the tough questions to
stakeholders
and a disgraced former Senator hit with
criminal charges that's coming up
a former senator who resigned from the
upper chamber amid scandals related to
alleged sexual misconduct is now facing
criminal charges Don Meredith has been
charged with three counts of sexual
assault and one count of criminal
harassment
Ottawa Police say the alleged incidents
took place in 2013 and 2014 and were
reported by an adult woman Meredith was
appointed to the Senate by former Prime
Minister Stephen Harper in 2010. he
resigned in 2017 after the Ethics
Committee recommended he be expelled for
using his position to pursue a sexual
relationship with a teen girl a second
investigation released in 2019 found he
had repeatedly bullied and intimidated
his staff as well as touched and kissed
some of them Meredith has been released
by police on a promise to appear in
court
Canada's healthcare system has been
making headlines for months now you've
likely heard about long emergency
weights Frontline staff at their wit's
end due to poor working conditions and
patients suffering unnecessarily maybe
you even experience this firsthand now
while provincial and federal politicians
say the problem has become a priority as
Jamie Maraca explains there are no plans
in place for an immediate fix
how are the semi-privates are they all
full emergency program director nurse
Jane Casey is no stranger to managing a
crisis how are the deterioration and
stuffer but it's the one she can't
control the hemorrhaging of hospital
staff that concerns her most it's been a
difficult time and I people want care
and they want care right away retention
has become a national issue and while
politicians have promised action
provinces have been pointing the finger
at Ottawa urging more Federal funding
I'm there to support them I know their
job is difficult but the Trudeau
government says monetary support won't
come without quote real tangible results
what that means exactly Canada's Health
Minister couldn't say and AS Global News
asked about the cash already pledged by
selection the government promised three
billion to hire family doctors where's
that money at Jeanie du Chloe walked
away we see our patients on stretchers
for days on end
um and we see
um a lack of nurses able to cover the
different parts of the ER in rural Perth
Ontario shortages forced the emergency
room to shutter on and off for months
the doors are back open now thanks to
private nursing staff a costly stop Gap
it is
back and forth does nothing for one of
my citizens it needs to get to the ER
Premier sat down with federal leaders
this summer and many Health ministers
say they've spoken to hospital heads
including purse all the the solutions
are not yet in place no and that's why
we're very concerned about the fall
still across the country it's the same
story no short-term fixes and no
timelines in Alberta surgical recovery
task force lead Ronan Seagraves says
implementing Solutions isn't simple some
change that needs to happen I will be
disruptive but it will be necessary if
it delivers the benefits that we all
want for patients and if there's any
delay can you let me know on timely
access and Quality Care should be what's
expected says Casey a priority and a
right for all Canadians Jamie moroccer
Global News Toronto
ahead swipe right for a family the
future fertility in a way you may not
have imagined
you're watching global national
[Music]
is when you want to start a family the
timing isn't quite right and that's when
some people look to fertility clinics
and sperm banks for help but those
options are usually limited to just
conceiving the baby not raising it
so what if you want more than just an
anonymous sperm donor Sophie Louie has
more on new options that are out there
Sophie
many people use dating sites in hopes of
ultimately finding a life partner
someone to build a family with but there
are now sites that let you skip that
dating part altogether and go straight
to building a family it sounds weird but
Yvonne fatovich is convinced he's onto
something you know it's a lot like
regular dating but for a different
purpose he's the founder of a website
called modamily when you want them to be
more involved in the kid's life it's
like a dating site but for people who
want to raise kids his clients can
choose to have varying degrees of
involvement in a child's life from just
the sperm or egg to occasional Hangout
to full-time co-parent
it's something that had particular
appeal to Stephanie reibel ideally I
would like a romantic relationship and a
partner that's ready to have a kid but I
like that this site can give me an
option for a platonic relationship which
kind of takes the pressure off so if I
do want to find somebody down the road
like at least then I've had
my children and I have a great co-parent
and then they can come into my life in a
romantic way and they can still be
involved modamily claims it has the
largest number of known sperm donors in
the world and where traditional sperm
banks are challenged in terms of
offering an ethnic diversity of donors
Yvonne says he doesn't struggle with
that issue it's a new era of Modern
Family Dynamics we'll Explore More on
how families are changing on the season
debut of the new reality pharah all
right look forward to it Sophie Louis
and burnabybc thank you and you can
catch Sophie's full report on
Innovations infertility and families on
the new reality as she mentioned that's
tonight at seven right here on global
next a plaque that's worth a thousand
words honoring a whistleblower from a
hundred years ago speaking out about
residential schools
a piece of advice that was widely
ignored a century ago is now getting the
recognition it deserves one hundred
years ago an Ontario doctor blew the
whistle on the atrocities of residential
schools calling them a National Crime
now he's being honored at the Ottawa
publishing house that released his work
Abigail Beeman reports
100 years ago in this very building a
report published by Dr Peter Bryce
called Canada's residential schools a
National Crime he was a highly qualified
prestigious
medically trained specialist who had
inspected the schools and said the
conditions and the circumstances are
deplorable and children are not only
sick they are dying and there's
something that can and should and must
be done about it and he was ignored
ignored years of dismissal from the
Department of Indian Affairs people back
then did know better people back then
had solutions to save children's lives
and that the pop-up was outraged but
when the headlines died so did the
children and that's a lesson we need to
take today Cindy Blackstock says
thousands of lives could have been saved
with that information a century ago and
yet schools kept running for decades
intergenerational trauma is real we're
in you know the third generation it
wasn't too long ago in my community that
they actually took the Bob wire off the
schoolyard
now a plaque will stand on the building
sharing the story of Dr Bryce in three
languages French English and Algonquin
we are proud of him some of his
great-grandchildren and even
great-great-great-grandchildren were
present for the unveiling he started the
process and here we are 115 years later
and we're still working on reparations
this plaque will be the first in
downtown Ottawa to highlight residential
schools but for years the first nation's
child and family caring Society has been
pushing for eight like it around the
downtown core and they hope that this
and the story of Dr Bryce is just the
beginning Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
and we've shown this to you before but
we want to do it again residential
school survivors and their families
looking for help can call the
residential school survivors and family
crisis line the number is on your screen
1-800-721-0066
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's York Canada is
gas Bay Quebec we love senior Canada so
please keep emailing us those photos to
viewers at globalnational.com until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other good night